[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
lorsqu'une personne est amoureuse on dit
qu'elle a des papillons dans le ventre
lorsqu elle est courageuse on dit
qu'elle a des tripes
lorsqu'une personne est déçu il faut
qu'elle digère la mauvaise nouvelle est
enfin lorsqu'une personne est stressé on
dit qu'à la boule au ventre et là croyez
moi quand on est au t2 10 devant mille
personnes on a la boule au ventre depuis
des années
depuis depuis des années nous utilisons
des expressions populaires qui met en
lien notre cerveau nos émotions avec
notre ventre sans savoir que nous
visions aussi juste alors vous l'avez
sûrement appris récemment dans la presse
dans les médias
le ventre est notre deuxième cerveau et
qui dit cerveau des neurones avez vous
idée du nombre de neurones que nous
possédons dans notre ventre 200 millions
de neurones pour vous donner une idée ça
correspond au cerveau d'un chat ou d'un
petit chien
alors c'est vrai que 200 millions de
neurones si on le compare au cerveau duo
qui lui en contient 90 milliards il est
vrai que c'est un peu petit cerveau mais
qui est suffisant pour assurer les
fonctions essentielles de notre
organisme comme la digestion ou le
transit intestinal
mais ce qui est encore plus passionnant
c'est que ce deuxième cerveau est en
contact direct avec le cerveau du haut
c'est à dire qu'il peut recevoir des
informations mais également en envoyer
comment est bien par les nerfs par
exemple le nerf vague relie nos deux
cerveaux ou pas la circulation sanguine
viala secret sion de neurotransmetteurs
ou d'hormones d'ailleurs saviez vous que
90% de la sérotonine qui est une hormone
qui régule le stress et l'émotion est
fabriquée non pas dans nos cerveaux diot
mais bel et bien dans notre ventre on
parle de lax intestins cerveau alors axe
un test un cerveau oui mais en fait si
nous voulions être plus précis nous
devrions parler de lax microbiote
intestins cerveau car en effet si on
zoome au coeur de nos entrailles au
coeur de notre trip nous pourrions
rencontrer les 40 à 100 mille milliards
de micro organismes de bactéries qui
vivent dans notre intestin
oui message à toutes les personnes qui
se sentent parfois un peu isolé vous
n'êtes jamais seul
alors ce chiffre de cent mille milliards
de micro organismes
ça signifie en fait que nous possédons
en ou dix fois plus de cellules non
humaine de cellules bactériennes que de
cellules humaines et ces bactéries
ces micro organismes ils ont aussi leur
propre adn leur propre patrimoine
génétique qui est différent du nôtre
ça donne le vertige qui sommes-nous
aujourd'hui je vous propose de partir à
la découverte du microbiote intestinal
afin de comprendre son importance mais
aussi sa fragilité à prendre en prendre
soin en préservant son équilibre donne
moi ton microbiote je te dirai qui tu es
le microbiote intestinal nous accompagne
au moins dès la naissance
dès nos premiers instants de vie par
exemple dès l'accouchement si la
naissance a lieu par voie basse par voie
naturelle
la colonisation du microbiote du
nouveau-né va se réaliser via la flore
bactérienne vaginale et fécales de la
maintenant en revanche si il est né par
césarienne
ce sera plutôt des bactéries qui sont
présentes dans l'environnement de la
salle d'accouchement ou du personnel
soignant et ce bébé ne bénéficiera pas
de la flore de la maman l'alimentation
aussi allaitement versus les industriels
un bébé qui sera nourri au sein de sa
mère va bénéficier de la flore ma mère
de la mer si je puis dire et le lait
maternel il a le privilège d'être d'être
d'être d'avoir une composition assez
forte en bifidobactéries et en
lactobacilles qui sont des bactéries qui
peuvent stimuler le système immunitaire
est façonné le microbiote intestinal
l'environnement aussi oui d'ailleurs
petite parenthèse c'est pour cela que le
contact peau à peau parents bébé est
essentiel pour le développement du micro
organismes afin que vous lui transférer
votre flore cutanée autre chose facteur
il ya également le l'environnement bébé
qui va grandir la campagne contact de la
nature va avoir un microbiote intestinal
différent de bébé
grandi en ville dans un appartement
désaffecté où j'avais autre chose
les traitements les traitements
antibiotiques bien qu'il soit nécessaire
pour traiter une infection ponctuelle
des traitements antibiotiques lors de la
petite enfance peuvent avoir un impact
sur la composition du microbiote
intestinal est en fait au fur et à
mesure des jours des semaines et même
des années ce microbiote intestinal va
évoluer pour au final se stabiliser dès
la fin de la petite enfance vers l'âge
de trois ans ensuite il deviendra unique
ce sera votre microbiote intestinal en
fait c'est un peu comme une empreinte
digitale
lorsqu'on regarde grossièrement elles se
ressemblent toutes
mais lorsqu'on approfondie l'analyse on
peut voir des différences entre chaque
individu est bien pour le microbiote
intestinal c'est un peu la même chose
il existe un socle d'espèces commun à
tout le monde à tous les individus mais
lorsqu on approfondit l'analyse les
différences subsistent
lorsqu'une personne est en bonne santé
oms dixons microbiote est en équilibre
en harmonie avec l'intestin et le
cerveau en équilibre mais pas pour
autant figés
il peut être sous l'effet il peut être
modulée subiat plusieurs facteurs des
facteurs qui peuvent induire un petit
déséquilibre ne ce microbiote intestinal
la prise de médicaments tels que les
antibiotiques des infections
bactériennes les changements hormonaux
comme la puberté ou la ménopause
le stress l'alcool est également le
régime alimentaire peuvent induire des
déséquilibres du microbiote intestinal
et induire des dommages gastro
intestinaux mais dans la littérature
scientifique
il a été écrit de plus fort déséquilibre
du microbiote intestinal qu'on appelle
10 bio c'est le cas dans certaines
pathologies des pathologies digestives
comme la maladie de crohn le syndrome de
l'intestin irritable le la rectocolite
hémorragique
alors concernant la maladie de crohn en
fait c'est une maladie inflammatoire
chronique de l'intestin qui connaît une
prévalence et une incidence en constante
augmentation et en fait les patients qui
vont souffrir cette pathologie vont
alterner avec des phases de rémission
les phases de repos et des phases de
crise qui vont se traduire par une
inflammation qui peut être très sévère
les symptômes vont être des crampes
abdominales diarrhée inflammation
douleur viscérale et il faut que vous
sachiez en fait qu'aujourd'hui on ne
connaît pas l'origine propre de la
maladie de crohn mais on sait que ce
sont des pathologies multifactorielles
c'est à dire qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs
qui rentrent en jeu
il ya des facteurs génétiques il ya le
système immunitaire il à l'environnement
les conditions de vie et il ya également
le microbiote intestinal via sadis bio
et ce qui est encore plus intéressant
c'est que l'ordonnancé pathologie
également dans le syndrome de l'intestin
irritable et bien elles sont sous
influence de lax microbiote intestins
cerveau c'est à dire qu'au-delà des
troubles gastro intestinaux
on constate aussi chez ces patients des
troubles du système nerveux central des
troubles comme des troupes de la
nociception du ressenti de la douleur de
l'émotion de l'humeur de l'anxiété du
stress alors au regard de la
communication entre microbiote intestins
et cerveau une des questions que l'on
peut se poser est est ce qu'une 10 bios
donc un déséquilibre du microbiote
intestinal peut contribuer au
développement de maladies neurologiques
et psychiatriques
alors je pose la question comme ça
allait bien entendu nous avons déjà
quelques éléments de réponse notamment
au niveau de la réponse au stress par
exemple la première démonstration
vraiment à 2004 quand une équipe
japonaise a permis de démontrer le lien
entre microbienne intestinale et stress
pour cela en fait ils ont pris des
animaux qui sont des animaux à eghezée
nick qui n'ont pas de microbiote
intestinal
ils sont stériles leur tube leur tube
digestif est stérile et ils ont remarqué
que ces animaux là eh bien il était plus
hyper sensible au stress et à l'anxiété
alors depuis il ya eu bien d'autres
études qui ont continué de le décrire ce
lien entre microbienne intestinale et
stress à la fois chez l'animal et chez
l'homme et par exemple chez l'homme les
patients qui souffrent de la maladie de
crohn qui
en rémission eh bien s'ils vivent un
événement stressant un stress
psychologique
et bien cela va induire une rechute de
la maladie ils vont passer en phase de
crise associé à une bisbille aux donc il
ya bien clairement aujourd'hui un lien
établi entre stress et microbiote
intestinal
alors outre le stress et les états
anxieux l'autisme l'autisme a aussi fait
l'objet de beaucoup de recherches et
fait encore actuellement l'objet de
beaucoup de recherches notamment par
exemple il ya une étude qui a comparé
les microbiote intestinal des enfants
autistes à ceux des enfants sains et ils
ont remarqué des différences
significatives
par exemple les microbes et de testing
halde enfants souffrant d'autisme et
moins variées - diversifier et se
ressemblent d'un patient à l'autre par
exemple généralement on va on va
observer une augmentation de bactéries
délétère comme des déçus il faut vibrio
et des stéroïdes et s est sont pas top
et une réduction des bifidobactéries et
des firmes eacute donc la recherche
avance à ce point là et avant quelques
années on pensait pas regarder dans le
ventre pour ces pathologies a alors le
microbiote intestinal a un effet
modérateur sur l'intestin on l'a vu avec
les pathologies digestives et également
sur le système nerveux central avec le
stress quels sont les moyens aujourd'hui
de modules et de tenter de rééquilibrer
ce microbiote intestinal
il faut que je vous parle actuellement
il y a des études qui sont en cours sur
la transplantation de microbiote plus
connu sous le nom de transplantation
fécale
vous avez bien entendu en fait le
concept vise à transférer le microbiote
intestinal d'un provenant des celle d'un
individu sain à un individu malade c'est
une vraie thérapie qui est encore
utilisé 1 au stade expérimental on est
encore en test c'est pas du tout
utilisées en routine et je pense que là
c'est un peu l'occasion de dire que les
chercheurs n'hésitent pas se salir les
mains pour servir la science
et cette thérapie a déjà fait a déjà
montré son efficacité notamment pour des
infections sévères à clostridium
difficile et mais comme je voulais dire
l'utilisent pas encore en routine parce
qu'on n'a pas encore assez de recul
alors il existe d'autres moyens beaucoup
plus accessible de rééquilibrer le
microbiote intestinal et vous en
connaissez certainement les
antibiotiques un antibiotique va par
définition à les tuer
une bactérie délétère ciblés dans
l'intestin
le problème c'est qu'elle va aussi
détruire un peu les autres bactéries qui
n'ont rien demandé mais les traitements
antibiotiques ont fait leurs preuves
dans la littérature scientifique on peut
lire que un traitement antibiotique
réduit les symptômes de pathologies
digestives et également concernant les
troubles du système nerveux central
une étude a montré chez l'animal que un
traitement antibiotique pouvait réduire
les symptômes d'autisme
lorsqu'il prenait ce traitement par
contre ils ont aussi constaté que dès
lors qu'on arrêtait le traitement
antibiotique
en fait les symptômes revenait ce qui
signifie que malheureusement on ne peut
pas proposer ce type de traitement
antibiotique sur ce type de trouble pour
ce type de pathologie qui sont sur la
durée à long terme parce que vous savez
très bien qu'il ait très peu recommandé
d'utiliser des antibiotiques à
répétition parce que tout simplement les
bactéries peuvent s'y habituer et
développer une résistance donc les
antibiotiques sont pas recommandés voilà
pour ce type de pathologie chronique
plutôt pour les infections ponctuelles
alors pas de panique il ya d'autres
moyens
les probiotiques par exemple les
probiotiques en fait ce sont des
bactéries vivantes que l'on va ingérée
et dont on connaît les fonctions et qu
on sait qu'elles ont un effet bénéfique
sur la santé
cela fait ses preuves pour les
pathologies digestives et également sur
des sur le stress chronique au des
probiotiques vous pouvez en trouver en
pharmacie en forte concentration mais
également de l'alimentation dans les
produits l'actos fermenter dans certains
laitages la soupe miso la saucisse des
cornichons autre moyen il ya également
les prébiotiques c'est pas pareil les
prébiotiques en fait ce sont les
nutriments que nous on ne peut pas
digérer mais que nos colloques nos
bactéries elles
elles peuvent en fait on va les nourrir
et donc en choisissant le type de
prébiotiques on peut choisir un peu le
type de bactérie dont on veut favoriser
la croissance comme les bifidobactéries
par exemple et des prébiotiques bien
vous pouvez en trouver naturellement de
l'alimentation notamment dans les fibres
les fibres sont source de prébiotiques
et tout ce qui est hors javaone peu à
part aux topinambours et enfin dernière
astuce vous pouvez trouver en pharmacie
dès symbiotique alors eu en fait ils
vont combiner sont des gélules on va
combiner à la fois les probiotiques donc
les bactéries et les prébiotiques leurs
nutriments tous ses moyens que je viens
de vous citer là sont utilisés
aujourd'hui dans le but de rééquilibrer
le microbiote intestinal
lorsqu'il ya dix bios malheureusement il
faut être bien clair là dessus que ce
soit dans le cas de pathologies
digestives comme la maladie de crohn le
syndrome de l'intestin irritable ou des
troubles du système nerveux central
ils ne permettent pas de guérir la
maladie je vous rappelle ce sont des
maladies multifactorielles
il n'y a pas que le microbiote qui est
mise en jeu mais cela permet tout de
même de réduire les symptômes et
d'améliorer la qualité de vie de passion
la recherche avance la découverte de
l'impact du microbiote intestinal sur le
cerveau apporte un nouveau point de vue
fondamental en neurosciences avant avant
on parlait de gastroentérologie pour le
vendre et de neurologie pour le cerveau
et de façon bien distinctes
aujourd'hui on parle bel et bien de
neurogastroentérologie ça signifie une
nouvelle façon de penser de nouveaux
concepts de nouveaux métiers de
nouvelles modalités thérapeutiques qui
peuvent permettre d'approcher de façon
différente les maladies notamment neuro
neurologique et demain dans le futur
demain peut-être que nous comprendrons
mieux les maladies neurodégénératives
actuellement des études des chercheurs
sont en train de se pencher sur la
question de savoir s'il ya un lien entre
microbiote intestinal et maladies
neurodégénératives je pense à alzheimer
parkinson sclérose en plaques
en attendant ses résultats je vous
souhaite de prendre soin de vous de
prendre soin de vos le microbiote
écouter votre ventre et essayer autant
que possible de conserver un esprit sain
dans un ventre sa patrie